an Tag 5 gab es einen unerwarteten Code
yellow der im Team zu Verwirrung führte
von welchem ihr in der Hauptserie nichts
erfahren habt wieder mit umgegangen
wurde und wie die tatsächliche Abholung
am Tag sechs aussah erfahrt ihr in
diesem Video vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren um uns zu unterstützen und
das große Finale des seven vs white
behands nächste Woche nicht zu verpassen
hi hier ist nochmal Martin von wandermut
und wir möchten uns nochmal bei dir dem
Zuschauer bedanken denn ohne dich wäre
das alles nicht möglich gewesen du weißt
vielleicht schon dass wir nicht nur
Abenteuer und Expeditionen planen
sondern auch richtig gute Auto
Bekleidung für Einsteiger und Profis
entwickeln getestet auf unseren
härtesten Expeditionen und Abenteuer und
damit auch perfekt geeignet für die Zeit
in der Natur daheim gerade jetzt wo es
draußen kalt wird merken wir wie gut
unsere wandermut Fleecejacke und unsere
Wollmützen sind sie halten selbst bei
anspruchsvollen Wanderung nicht nur warm
sondern auch trocken noch dazu sehen Sie
im Alltag echt gut aus als Zuschauer von
Seven bekommst du mit dem Code Dave noch
mal 10% oben drauf wir freuen uns schon
darauf Dich bei der nächsten Wanderung
im wandermut Outfit anzutreffen dann
wissen wir du bist einer von uns und
kein langweiliger pauschalurist oder
schönwetterwanderer schau gerne mal bei
wandermut.de vorbei den Link findest du
unten in der Beschreibung und jetzt
weiterhin viel Spaß beim Schauen der
Serie
also wenn Sie eine Speicherkarte
verloren hat dann wird es kein wird sie
das nicht witzig dass ich jucken also
sie wird wahrscheinlich hier raus ne sie
hat wahrscheinlich alle aber basierenlo
Holt mich hier raus geschickt
ging schon ziemlich verwirrt also das
gelesen
[Musik]
brauche dringend lichtspeicherkarte weg
von gestern sie hat eine Lampe
[Musik]
im Telefonat wurde klar dass Sabrina
eine der 14 SD-Karten verloren hat am
Morgen des fünften Tages sprang eine der
SD-Karten durch den Federmechanismus der
GoPro in die Steine ihres Strandes in
der Panik sendete sie dem Team ein
kordillero um um mit Hilfe beim Suchen
der SD-Karte zu bitten laut Regelwerk
für dies jedoch zu Ausschluss aber wenn
das die eine Speicherkarte betrifft von
gestern dann kommen wir jetzt nicht raus
zu dir ne dann ist der eine Tag weg aber
wir kommen nicht raus
was passiert also es ist kein Code
yellow offensichtlich hat sie
jetzt in der Panik das kurzsystem Gut
durcheinander gebracht und yellow heißt
rausholen also ich werte das jetzt wie
ein Code yellow der abgebrochen wurde
hier würde ich auch so sagen so
angerufen oder wollte dass sie kommen
und Licht bringen oder so oder
ja aber dann wäre sie heraus das weiß ja
das wahrscheinlich in Aufregung ist
alles gut okay also wir lassen ja
aber eigentlich ist sie halt raus oder
ich finde das unfassbar schwierig ne wie
war das Protokolle dass sie sich wieder
melden wenn sie nicht mehr in der Lage
sind weiterzuführen Champions in meinem
Briten nein das haben wir aber beide
außer hintereinander ausführlich erklärt
und wir haben auch ausführlich danach
gefragt haben dass alle verstanden das
muss jetzt auch Bedenken überlegt mal
das Briefing und krank das war wie lang
das vielen Informationen also dass sie
das jetzt immer weiß deshalb ist
wir haben gerade einen Code yellow
bekommen von Sabrina aber in der
Einzelfall Entscheidung beschlossen dass
wir sie obwohl sie Kontakt zum Thema
hatte nicht rausholen weil es
unverhältnismäßig wäre wir hatten eine
sehr lange Briefing Tag so dass
wahrscheinlich so davon gehen wir aus
nur hängen geblieben ist bei ihr das ist
okay ist sich bei einem Technikfehler
beim Team zu melden springen nach
Protokoll wäre sie raus gewesen aber
es ist auch einfach uncool erstens für
die Serie und wenn wir sie rausholen
würden und zweitens für sie weil ich
glaube sie hat einen guten Glauben uns
zu informieren das gemacht und nicht
weil sie jetzt so dringend Kontakt zu
uns wollte weil ich glaube eher aus
Angst irgendwas
Wasser ist gut alles gut alles klar supi
wir machen jetzt sozusagen das bedeutet
bzw Evakuierung des Dauer ist denke
Stunde anderthalb ungefähr sind wir bei
dir wenn sich irgendwas ändern sollte
kannst du jederzeit einfach wieder
abführen okay alles klar bis gleich Ciao
so das war Sabrina gewesen ich weiß kein
schlechter Tag zeigen
es ist Sonntag auf der Insel sabrina hat
gerade eben angerufen mit einem Coach
yellow ich habe gerade eben mit dir
telefoniert sie ist nicht in irgendeiner
Gefahr sie ist nicht verletzt ich glaube
sie ist einfach Möbel durch die Zeit
durch die Einsamkeit bisschen Durst hat
sie wir sollen ihr was zu trinken
mitbringen und ansonsten würde ich sagen
machen wir uns jetzt mal fertig und
fahren rüber gut yellow jetzt kein
Fehler Alarm jetzt echter Code yellow
von Sabrina sie hat am Telefon gesagt
sie hat genug warum weil sie jetzt nicht
vielleicht diese Situation vielleicht
Erschöpfung vielleicht die Mischung aus
allem
Sabrina ich bin Auto Youtuberin ich gehe
mit einer gesunden Nervosität
Rack räume ich auch richtig und ich
glaube mein großes Ziel wird es sein ein
Fisch zu fangen
[Musik]
letzte Abenteuer Beginn also ich muss
wirklich sagen
erster Eindruck ist für mich richtig
wohl gerade und gerade bisschen
glücklich
geil Alter ich habe mein Profil ich bin
einfach so happy gerade weil ich jetzt
einfach weiß ich kann diesen sieben Tage
schaffen ich kann es halt jetzt wirklich
durchhalten
das sind Stacheln ich merke gerade dass
die nächsten 7 Tage hart werden aber
darüber bin ich gerade sehr happy das
ist ein kleines Erfolgserlebnis und
macht mich sehr glücklich da hinten am
Horizont
hat es gerade geblitzt es wird eine
Horror Nacht
und die sieben Tage werden richtig
richtig hart ich bin echt mal gespannt
wie es den anderen Teilnehmern geht ob
den Feuer hinbekommen haben ob die in
einigermaßen sichere Shelter hinbekommen
haben mir geht's den Umständen
entsprechend sehr sehr gut ich habe das
Gefühl ich komme halt irgendwie so gar
nicht voran
hat mich ein bisschen was verändert wie
Ihr vielleicht seht also ich fühle mich
jetzt schon viel viel viel viel wohler
er ist jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
gespannt jetzt brauche ich noch ein
Pfeil und dann können wir das erste mal
testen ob das Ding was bringt
das ist der schlechteste Bogen den ich
je in meinem Leben gebaut habe
[Musik]
oh Gott und ich habe jetzt schon
irgendwie so einen Anfall von
vermissen warum mache ich das eigentlich
warum
tue ich mir das an
crazy
ich freue mich gerade total dass die
rechte Seite trocken hält
und so Andreas
wenn es heute im Laufe des Tages nicht
aufhört zu regnen weiß ich nicht wie ich
die Nacht überstehen soll ehrlich gesagt
ich habe überhaupt noch gar nicht alles
erlebt auf dieser Insel was ich gerne
erleben möchte und ich möchte diese
Insel noch nicht verlassen
ich bin völlig fertig
mir geht's richtig beschissen mir geht's
richtig beschissen ich habe schon wieder
einen Splitter im Fuß oh scheiße
ich hoffe da ist eine Pinzette drin ich
habe es jetzt echt ein Problem
erstmal wirklich Zusammenbruch
das ist echt krass was ich halt jetzt
hier schon für eine Scheiße durch habe
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie das
ist wenn man die ganze Nacht nicht
geschlafen hat seit vier Tagen irgendwie
nichts gegessen hat
[Musik]
den ganzen struggle den ich mit dem
Shelter hatte manche Eltern sind immer
noch nicht so dass ich sage ich kann
mich da dann wohl fühlen weil es einfach
super unbequem ist da drin zu schlafen
ich würde jetzt so gern
ich bin jetzt so gerne einfach weil
meine Liebste Abend
zwar ist es jetzt das zweite Mal in der
kompletten Zeit dass ich überlege mich
abholen zu lassen und ich habe Kreislauf
ich habe Durchfall
kein Kokoswasser survival
dessen auf und ab wie glücklich es mich
gerade macht scheiß fucking Kokosnuss
Wasser zu trinken mir wird gerade
bewusst ich habe alles was ich brauche
jetzt kommt nur noch darauf an wie mein
Kopf mitspielt und diesmal war die Flug
so hart das ist mein komplettes Shelter
auseinander gerissen hat also wenn man
Shelter im Arsch ist da kein nach Hause
gehen meine Laune ist echt tierisch im
Arsch tierisch im Arsch könnte das
funktionieren mit der Spitze
ey das gibt's doch nicht verdammte
scheiße
was ist das für ein Dreck Mann
[Musik]
mein Geschenk für die Community für die
Verlosung von Seven vs wild guten Morgen
heute ist Tag 6 im Projekt 7 vs white
und ich habe mich heute Nacht dafür
entschieden
die Insel bzw diesen Spot hier zu
verlassen
[Musik]
ich bin natürlich schon ein bisschen
traurig weil mein Ziel war es wirklich
die ganze Zeit am letzten Tag mit den
übrigen Teilnehmern abgeholt zu werden
und es liegt nicht an meiner Leistung es
liegt nicht an meinem Durchhaltevermögen
sondern es liegt jetzt einfach daran
dass es mir ansonsten ja zu gefährlich
wird so wir sehen Sie schon Sabrina
steht am Strand sie hat eben die Fackel
gezündet hat uns auch noch mal genau
gezeigt damit wo sie genau zu finden ist
und jetzt noch
vielleicht 200 Meter dann hat es
geschafft dann holen wir sie aus
[Musik]
für eine Rettung
ich freue mich so euch zu sehen ne das
glaube ich
wie war es
übelst krass ich kann das gar nicht in
Worte fassen
was für eine krasse der tonale machen
aber nicht betroffene
oh Gott so und ich habe gesehen dass das
Medical aufgerissen was ja nice gefällt
mir
war nötig
[Gelächter]
mega
gezogen deswegen habe ich das auch
gemacht aber
der alte hat sogar schon ein bisschen
raus das nice wie es mit Wasser und so
naja ich kann schon so ein bisschen
also das Ding ist mein süßwasserspot war
dann irgendwann voller Regenwasser übers
Peking und da musste ich mir halt abends
tatsächlich noch Wasser abkochen was
aber ganz kurze Zunge raus lass mal
jetzt hast du schon was getrunken okay
alles klar danke schön
[Gelächter]
also definitiv davon ein bisschen
trocken gewesen so also kreislaufmäßig
man merkt das so Position schwarz ist
ein bisschen schneller ist auch die
Aufregung
ja Wasser Wasser Wasser so also ich
meine man merkt es tatsächlich definitiv
so das ist ein bisschen schwächer ist
und ähm außer der durchblutungszustand
und alles also da kannst du mal
nachbauen das würde gute und so drei
vier Liter mal rein so das wird es
definitiv sein und dann wird es besser
sein
ich freue mich so euch zu sehen
Sabrina worauf freust du dich am meisten
jetzt
eine Dusche ich freue mich nicht mal
essen ich habe gar keinen Hunger ehrlich
gesagt und dusche ich freue mich diesen
ganzen Schmodder abzuwaschen dann auch
mal so ein bisschen Wunden lecken also
hier desinfizieren sauber machen Haare
kämmen Augenbrauen zupfen rasieren
eincremen kuschelklamotten ja darauf
freue ich mich meistens definitiv
er ist halt nicht mehr viel zu erkennen
irgendwie da drin hatte ich halt so
längst
ein Bett mit so Querstreben wie so ein
Lattenrost falsch aber ist halt jetzt
alles auseinandergefallen dass das
einzige was ich halt gerne noch gemacht
hätte ich wäre gerne mal den Fluss ein
bisschen runtergegangen und dann hätte
ich halt gerne mal gesehen was sich so
dahinter befindet ich bin halt nur da
einmal den Berg hoch und so ein bisschen
in die Richtung aber ansonsten habe ich
glaube ich fast alles gemacht was ich
hier auf einer Insel hätte machen wollen
oder was so mir wichtig war jetzt ab
nach hause ja ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mich heute Nacht entschieden habe zu
gehen ich war auch so glücklich ne ich
dachte du wolltest es ist einfach genau
der richtige Moment zu gehen ne
[Musik]
bei mir war halt auch irgendwann die
Socke die halt also ich habe halt auch
echt hier so am hier
ja
genau immer also Hose und dann halt
Sockel drüber genau
[Musik]
oder genau
das ist der Beginn von John rot das ist
erstmal nicht schlimm diese Phase ist
das heißt
geworden aber die ganze Zeit in den
Schulen wäre halt irgendwann dieser
dieser
kleinen schwarzen Punkte auf und die
entzündet sich wunderbar
zusehen dass Du das wieder eine kriegst
in der Regel kriegst du es nicht wieder
ein oder so also jeden Tag wieder in der
Farbe
dann kannst du ja auch nicht laufen wenn
das Unternehmen doch kannst du aber
jeden Tag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo hallo
[Musik]
draufgesetzt haben
das war ein bisschen eklig essen
vier volle Tage Dschungel und jetzt die
erste Pommes
okay
[Musik]
tut gut
aber ich muss sagen Hunger war nicht das
Problem ich hatte die ganze Zeit gar
keinen Hunger also Hunger schon mal aber
gar kein Appetit also ich habe dann
irgendwann gegessen weil ich gemerkt
habe ich brauche halt Energie aber nicht
weil ich ja Hunger hatte oder dachte ich
muss jetzt unbedingt was essen
wahrscheinlich ist doch zu genießen sehr
toll ihr seid alle neidisch
also
passieren
zurückgekommen ist ist das eingetreten
was ich allen Leuten vorher nicht gesagt
habe aber was normalerweise einer meiner
cases ist im Tropen jede Wunde infiziert
sich das ist nicht wirklich schlimm weil
ihr weil es ist absolut oberflächlich
aber kann man hier sehen hier sehen auf
der anderen Seite sind wirklich nur
oberflächliche so Abschürfungen letzten
Endes aber nächstes sofort zu infiziert
das gute ist das in diesem Erste Hilfe
jetzt die Teilnehmer alle mit dabei
hatten tatsächlich alles schon ist was
man braucht so dann nehmen wir jetzt
einfach ein bisschen sagen wunderbar
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
einfach ein Stück Handschuh Handschuhe
eignen sich fantastisch für Salben
verwende einfach nur weil die Salbe
unten drunter nicht abbaut schneiden uns
im Endeffekt was raus so groß wie wir es
brauchen das ist der Grund gewesen warum
wir so viele Handschuhe mit gehabt hat
einfach nur damit man die Plaste mit aus
einem Verband benutzen kann
[Musik]
dann bestes tape
der absolute
[Musik]
so wundervoll das war's gewesen
jetzt habe ich neue Füße bekommen
[Musik]